okay so getting into the Batman tie-in
for Green Lantern blackest night this is
actually pretty cool and a lot of the
tie ends are they're actually a lot more
interesting that you would think they
would be because the tie ends as a whole
serve the purpose of like beefing up the
whole blackest night story but also
showing us what these different
characters are doing at the time that
blackest night is happening what's but
the Justice Society is doing what
Superman is doing what Batman's doing so
on so forth this one of course again
will focus on Batman but the idea with
the first part of the story which is to
say the video that we covered last week
that part of the story was designed to
focus on the fact that the dead were
basically just rising now we knew it was
because of Black Lantern rings the
superheroes of Earth were slowly
starting to figure out it was Black
Lantern rings but they didn't realize
how big it was but again this story
actually comes as part of the aftermath
of the death of Batman now the death of
Batman was actually a pretty big moment
in the realm of DC Comics and the reason
why is because writer Grant Morrison had
basically taken a pinup and written
Final Crisis but the idea was that
Morrison wanted to basically rework the
Batman mythos were at the very least
start this new saga of Batman and so
really it was like this three-part
trilogy more or less it was Final Crisis
where Batman was believed to have died
at the hands of Darkseid and then it was
the return of Bruce Wayne which actually
told us that Batman didn't talk instead
he was basically time-displaced
going all the way back to the earliest
days of mankind and literally working
his way up through the history of
humanity back to the modern day now of
course at this moment right now when
this tie-in is being written
Batman's believed to have been dead we
know he's in the past but nobody else
knows that and so ultimately what is up
happening is that because the fact that
the rise of the Black Lanterns basically
led to William hand kind of like this
avatar of the Black Lantern Corps so to
speak or basically their first member
traveling to the to the Wayne cemetery
more or less grabbing the skull of Bruce
Wayne and then racing off what it also
did is it disturb the remains of Thomas
and Martha Wayne now in terms of why
William hand took the skull or at least
the Percy
skull of Bruce Wayne it's actually
something that's explained later on now
keep in mind when the story's written
everybody thinks is Bruce Wayne
everybody thinks the body and that
confident is Bruce Wayne of course I
don't mind dropping that little bit of a
spoiler just because of the fact that by
now it's pretty much common knowledge
among most people that Bruce met the Oh
Batman didn't actually die but it's
still kind of a bit of an interesting
situation because from the perspective
of Dick Grayson and Damian Wayne it is
disrupting family remains rumor you know
Damian Wayne is the only real biological
son of Bruce but when you're Dick
Grayson and from the time you were a
child until the time you're an adult you
fought alongside Bruce Wayne you might
as well be Finn who might as well be a
father figure or a brother or something
along those lines
and so to Dick Grayson Thomas and Martha
Wayne might as well be grandparents
that's really what they are to him
because he's so close to Bruce's so the
most logical step to take is to grab the
remains and then whisk them off to Wayne
tower put them in a bunker where they'll
be safe and so that nobody can disturb
them and then perhaps even bring them
back at some later point in time but
what this does is the switches over to a
character named Boston brand also known
as Deadman
now we talked about Deadman a little bit
in the first video we didn't really do
him justice just because of the fact
that I intended to do this tie-in and he
does have a much bigger role and so I
figure if he would wait until this time
to actually beef up an explanation on
him but Boston brand was a character who
appeared back in 1967 and he was part of
this wholesale attempt by DC to
basically begin introduce you the
concept are really focusing more on the
concept of like mysticism the dark arts
different things like that
truth to tell a Superman is not the
first superhero per se that DC had
released in fact that really goes all
the way back to 1935 and a guy named dr.
occult the difference is that Superman
had powers dr. occult was basically just
a detective that focused on like
superstitious things and someone so
forth he dealt with the whole mystery
and you know angels and ghosts and
different things like that most
modern-day superheroes are based on
Superman which is why people say
Superman is the first superhero
quote-unquote one of the first
characters are really the first
character to have
and true powers but between dr. occult
characters like Zatara who also appeared
and actually comics number one the
father of Zatanna with these characters
who have been created over the years
John Constantine in 1984 the idea was
that ICI wanted to begin moving towards
the direction of saying okay so we have
our superheroes Wonder Woman flash
Batman Superman Green Lantern and so on
and then we have the other side of the
equation we have ghosts we have angels
we have demons we have monsters all that
kind of good stuff and all that is over
here on this side with dead man Boston
brand with John Constantine with Jason
blood with dr. occult with cetana
all that kind of stuff it's vertigo it's
a whole different beast for the most
part the idea with Deadman with Boston
brand is that he was originally a guy
who was murdered and basically was given
the ability to jump from one host body
to the next to find his murderer now
when it comes to Boston brand while he
is able to possess bodies he's limited
by the body that he possesses and so if
for example he were to like possess
Superman and then he were to turn around
and possess Batman he would not be able
to carry the powers of Superman with him
over to Batman it doesn't work that way
instead what he basically does is just
jump from one body to the next now when
he possesses a body he has full access
to all their memories all their
experiences and so on and all that went
towards him trying to track down the
person that killed him but in this
instance what Boston brand actually
reveals here is that these dead bodies
that are coming back to life are not the
actual dead bodies of people which is to
say when his corpse comes back it's not
him as an individual who's an actual
black lantern instead it's just the
bodies being used as puppets more or
less it's really the way it is the
essence of him as a human being still
floats around as a ghost the body of
Boston bran is being used now the reason
why this matters is because it's not an
actual resurrection from the dead it's
not like you know Thomas and Martha
Wayne their spirits have been whisked
away from the afterlife thrown back into
their bodies and they're possessed you
know by the Black Lantern rings and
suddenly started tacking everybody and
it doesn't work that way if that were
the case Boston brand spirit would have
been restricted to his body and then he
would have been running around as a
black lantern and so the idea is that
these are basically just corpses of
people their essences story
but they're basically just puppets that
are being used for the purpose of the
Black Lanterns to beef up their numbers
now at this point we switch over to all
these different villains again when it
came to the idea that the Black Lanterns
were basically rising and that those
people villains heroes or otherwise who
had died were coming back one of the
things that the various superheroes
began to do was take these villains of
these various you know I guess take the
bodies of these various villains and
start whisking them away to safe places
so the black lantern rings could not
access them in this instance Black
Lantern rings show up on this basically
this transport this carrying all these
bodies of these villains and then you
know they essentially get black lantern
rings and they all just start running
amok and so again things get a little
crazy and things get a little hairy
because when it comes to this whole idea
of blackest night and the Dead coming
back it actually leads to some really
really cool discussions case in point
Dick Grayson begins talking to Damian
Wayne and the two of them are discussing
the concept of death are they afraid of
it
now of course dick Grayson's answer is
no but the reason why is because his
role as a superhero is mired in death
his parents were killed you know by Zuko
they were basically killed you know
because the circus owner you know
wouldn't Bend Anita Zuko and the result
was that he sabotage the trash be on the
trapeze act the most popular act that
the that Hayley circus had going at the
time and as a result dick Grayson's
parents were killed his life is rooted
in death who he is now is a byproduct of
the fact that those he knows those that
he loved the most were basically killed
for Damian Wayne he's never really faced
anything like this before
Damian Wayne's never really been in a
situation where he had to face the fact
that he was going to die at least not
yet now there does come a point where
Damian Wayne does die and has actually
brought back but at the moment he's
basically just this kid who was or who
is the biological son of Bruce Wayne he
was trained by the League of Assassins
and ultimately handed back over to Bruce
Wayne and he became Robin and that's
really about it
he hasn't had to face his own mortality
before and that's why this is sort of
cool is because this is basically a
young kid who in all forms and fashion
also outside of the physical structure
of his body is an adult in a lot of
different ways being forced to look at
the idea that a time will come when he
will die now of course this immediately
it's really
cut short by the arrival of Boston brand
who just basically jumps into the body
of Dick Grayson and then just start
sputtering all this nonsense about all
they're coming back and they're hungry
and so on and so forth and of course it
creates some panic because Robin has no
idea what's happening all he knows is
that Dick Grayson is having like an
episode he just starts freaking out
babbling at the mouth about Black
Lanterns about how they were there you
know consuming people's hearts how
they're dying for energy all that kind
of good stuff
now of course again we covered that
aspect in the first part of the blackest
night videos which is to say that the
black Lantern's themselves basically
empower the central power battery the
source of their abilities by going
around invoking all these emotions and
people when they evoke emotions like
hate fear different things like that it
literally just charges up their hearts
and so the black Lantern's kill him can
you know reach into their chest consume
their hearts and that energy goes into
the Black Lantern Corps are the I'm
sorry the Black Lantern central power
battery providing it more energy and
ultimately raising it to 100% which
would allow Necron the living embodiment
of death in the DC Universe to walk into
the earthly plane so again is pretty
cool in terms of how this unfolds
because it all really begins to tie
together now of course because Damian
Wayne has no experience with Deadman but
Dick Grayson does ultimately Deadman
jumps from Dick Grayson into Damian
Wayne and this is when Dick Grayson
begins to realize what it is that's
happening now remember it really Dick
Grayson knowing who Deadman is and just
a byproduct of having fought as Robin
alongside Batman for so long when you're
that sidekick you just basically get a
tour of everything in the DC Universe
you get a tour of all the magic all the
sorcery all the other superheroes all
the villains different things like that
you fight alongside Superman in a
multitude of different different
scenarios so you basically learn
everything that you need to learn not
only this Dick Grayson comes to the
realization that if the graves of Thomas
and Martha Wayne have been disturbed and
that these rings are flying around and
resurrecting these dead folks then it
makes sense that it's only a matter of
time before the Rings seek out two other
sets of parents the first being his own
the second being the parents of Tim
Drake now of course when this happens
when they arrive at this you know at
this this grave site only to discover
that Thomas and I'm sorry that uh that
the parents of Dick Grayson have
erected that we also end up finding out
do the parents of Tim Drake have also
come back now Tim Drake's an interesting
scenario when it comes to the Batman
landscape when it comes to the
chronology of the Robins the first Robin
was Dick Grayson the second was Jason
Todd the third was Tim Drake and the
fourth was Damian Wayne Tim Drake is one
of those characters whose popularity is
contextual which is to say people only
really liked him when he's Robin and
that people who liked him the most were
people who basically grew up with him so
when they follow Tim Drake when he first
popped up and he became Robin then he
moved beyond Robin and he became Red
Robin those fans maintained their love
for him they were just like I don't care
whether he's Red Robin I don't care
whether he's Robin whatever I love Tim
Drake other people on the other hand who
were not as familiar with his character
maybe read about him in passing or
different things like that were really
relegated to either being fans of him as
Robin or fans of him as Red Robin it was
just whenever they happened to pick up
his comic so again that's par for the
course when it comes to comic books
right like fans latch on to a particular
character for whatever reason some fans
even that I'm not really sure why but
some fans even tie their identities into
those characters if you don't like that
character you don't like me I'm not
really sure why people do that but some
folks do but regardless of the scenario
people grow to love these particular
comic book characters and so ultimately
what is up happening is that with this
revelation with Tim Drake as Red Robin
being recalled B Gotham City ultimately
it is the you know Batman spotlight
being thrown up into the sky and Dick
Grayson realizing we have to answer the
call now because of the fact that
Deadman can only really be seen by those
that he's possessed or those and he
chooses to allow to see him you know
what ends up happening is he actually
just races off and does a little bit of
like recon work you know and this
ultimately leads to Dick Grayson and Amy
and realizing that they cannot beat
these black Lantern's through fists
instead what they need are all manner of
weapons they can get their hands on
because again for the most part they
don't really know how to combat these
guys they don't really know how to
defeat the Black Lanterns per se again
but you know fighting punching different
things like that
doesn't really do any good and so what
they do is they actually travel to an
armory and they basically load
themselves up with everything rocket
launchers flamethrowers the whole nine
yards I mean they are they are ready for
war
is man Katie bar the door they are
prepped for battle and so again what
this also does is it leads into the idea
that the Gotham City Police Department
you know of course you know basically
led by Commissioner Gordon is having his
men just slaughtered all over the place
because he's Black Lanterns again
basically thrive on death charge people
you know emotionally charged people with
fear anger rage you know all that kind
of good stuff the hope that things will
get better someone and so forth and when
their hearts are at their absolute peaks
kill him eat them and then feed the
Black Lanterns central power battery
that's exactly what's happening here the
fact that there's some guy that's
basically patrolling around going around
the Gotham City Police Department that
none of the cops can kill but who in
turn is killing every copy comes across
terrifies everybody it's absolutely
horrifying at the same time for
Commissioner Gordon it's not just his
guys that is worried about his different
police you know it's really Barbara
Gordon that he's concerned about Noor so
than anybody else not the events of
Barbara Gordon in terms of her being
confined to a wheelchair again this is
all basically aftermath of The Killing
Joke
now the funny thing about this is
originally The Killing Joke was never in
continuity it was just a story out there
somewhere where it was basically just
you know the Joker's shot Barbara Gordon
and then he made you know her father
Commissioner Gordon look at all these
lewd pictures of her as far as I'm aware
the actual writer of the story never
said that Batman killed the Joker Alan
Moore the guy who originally wrote the
story he never said Batman killed the
Joker um I think it was it was grant
Moore sue said he believed Batman did
but Grant Morrison never wrote it so for
all that weight that carries I say
Batman didn't kill the Joker and now
we're even so the idea is that with
Barbara Gordon I'm sort with The Killing
Joke being so popular DC rolled it over
into continuity and the result is that
Barbara Gordon went forward paralyzed
and so at this moment right now she
actually serves the role of a character
called Oracle and in truth I think
that's actually the best iteration of
her character because she was basically
the brains behind the operation the
behind the scenes character who was
feeding all these superheroes all this
Intel on
take down these different villains and
so on and so forth she basically became
a linchpin for the intelligence arm of
the superhero community which was really
really cool within the realm of DC but
the issue here is that Barbara Gordon is
confined to a wheelchair which means she
can't just run off she's basically stuck
to being able to move as fast as she can
now Commissioner Gordon literally
shields himself from every possible
thing her shields her from every
possible thing that could kill her but
at the end of the day it's trying to get
her out of there as fast as he can but
at the same time she doesn't necessarily
want to leave and that's why a lot of
people loved the character of world form
because it's not like she was last in
first out she was like look I'm here and
I'm gonna stay here until this is done
and that's one of the reasons why she
was so cool is because like she would
fight until the bitter end
like she would she'd fight just like
anybody else now of course what we also
end up finding out is that these various
villains had an escape for you notice
this transport out with Black Lantern
rings were the ones who initiated this
whole you know Batman Searchlight in the
process and so of course with Dick
Grayson the Damian Wayne showing up here
flamethrowers the whole nine yards what
they end up doing is saving these guys
off as best they can but then we also
end up having Boston brand jumping into
the body of Barbara Courtney now the
problem with this and the idea of this
is that Boston brand believes that he
can actually save Barbara by basically
getting her out of it now the problem of
this of course is that this goes back
into the idea that Boston brand a dead
man is confined to the abilities of the
body he possesses and this instance
Barbara Gordon has lost her ability to
walk therefore Boston brand while in his
body or in her body cannot walk and so
of course it allows him to be a little
more ingenuitive then Barbara Gordon
usually would be in the sense of this
kind of jumping out but also using this
you know these these various bits of
knowledge that both he has and she's
learned over the years but one of the
big things is that in possessing her
body
he actually realizes there's a lot of
history between Dick Grayson and Oracle
which is to say they were a romantic
couple for quite some time and it was
pretty hot and pretty heavy I mean they
really really got into it with one
another but the idea here is that it's
basically just kind of again hitting
back home at the
applause we're heading back home and
what it is least capable of these
different things that equal view what
they also end up finding out is that
with these black lanterns they can be
defeated they can be taken out and the
way we learn this is actually pretty
cool initially it comes by way of a
couple things the first is the demon
Etrigan and the second is really just by
way of sheer ingenuity from Dick Grayson
now when it comes to enter again he's
actually one half of the equation really
entered in and Jason blood share this
kind of Bruce Banner Incredible Hulk
dichotomy in the sense that were
incredible Hawks just a byproduct of
genetic manipulation at the hands of a
gamma bomb when Bruce Banner tested it
and got caught in the blast
Etrigan is actually a demon who is bound
to the soul of a guy named Jason blood
but what it does is it allows Etrian to
pop up every once in a while and so
because of this when a chicken does show
up all hell breaks loose because it's
basically a demon a demon from Hell just
unleashing absolute chaos on the world
now in truth the arrival of him being
here just comes by way of Deadman in the
sense the Deadman simply shows up
knocking on the door of Jason blood
Jason blood turns him away I'm sorry
Deadman jumped into the body of Jason
blood and then simply
utters the incantation utters the phrase
gone gone the form of man arrives the
demon Etrigan so what this ends up doing
is it allows Etrigan as he's possessed
by by Deadman to show up on the
battlefield now the other half of this
is that with the forces of Batman I
guess of Dick Grayson and you know
Damian Wayne and Red Robin and so on
going in and trying to figure out a way
to defeat these black Lantern's while at
the same time getting as many people to
safety as they can what ends up actually
happening here is is really Red Robin
stumbles across his own father and this
is cool because unlike the other Black
Lanterns his father's actually a good
guy his father is basically like hey
look no matter what happens here I'm
proud of
you've done I'm proud of everything that
you've accomplished now all this
basically seems to go away in the face
of the fact that all these different
members Dick Grayson Davy and Wayne not
Tim Drake so on and so forth they're all
basically made to face these nightmares
of sorts in the sense that with Zuko
having been the person that was
responsible for the death of dick
Grayson's parents
Zucco's arrival literally just like
signifies absolute hatred on behalf of
Dick Grayson and he literally just
lashes out and starts attacking now the
other half of this is that their
impending deaths are actually staved off
by the arrival of a Trojan
like literally at your game possess my
dad man shows up using Hellfire and
using all these different abilities that
he has is able to stave off against all
these different black Lantern's and
really just kind of give a moment of
panic now in truth because Etrigan is a
demon his men being bonded to the black
Lantern's would be a huge benefit to the
Black Lantern Corps the problem with
this is he doesn't really have a heart
to speak of and so the result is that as
he's possessed or at least as a black
Lantern's trying to kill him and take
his heart ultimately they're
unsuccessful this coincides with the
fact that uh that that Etra gun actually
banishes you know Deadman from his body
and says I don't know what it is you
think you're doing and I have no idea
what's going on here but I'm not worried
about it I got bigger fish to fry and
just takes off well he literally just
leaves he just bails out and so again
what isn't happening is Dick Grayson
using one of the guns of Mr Freeze
actually freezes himself Damian Wayne
and Jason I'm sorry and and Tim Drake
and then the Black Lanterns are just
kind of left looking for them and they
can't actually find out where they're at
and so it's really just kind of like a
shielding basically duping them and it's
cool the way it plays out
and the reason for this is because of
the fact that once the black Lantern's
leave this allows Batman it allows his
team to go forward and basically say
okay so this is like a stopgap measure
this is a way to basically hide
yourselves from the Black Lanterns the
problem with this is that it's not a
foolproof way you have to actually
defeat the Black Lanterns as opposed to
hiding but it does allow a way for a
superhero to basically remain hidden if
things end up going to pot too hard too
fast and that's what we're gonna find
with a lot of these tie-ins we're gonna
find moments where heroes basically find
a way to stave themselves off from the
black Lantern's ultimately leading to
the
second half of the story which is when
things really get nuts so with that
being said guys if you are new here to
come as explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]